good to be here hey how you doing nice
to see you hey good shirt
how are you cleavage that's exciting
ah hey don't get weird you brought it
all right
here we are sorry i gotta work on saying
things to people out loud
yeah i got a problem i just say what i
see i think i'm autistic but just like
the bad parts of it
you know like i can't compute numbers or
remember dates but
i'll make you feel weird right like you
drop a bunch of toothpicks i can't count
them but i'll give you a shitty hug
i'm working on it trying to get better
flew here from new york
man i hate flying you know they let you
pick your seat on a plane i think i'd
rather pick the person i'm sitting next
to
i don't really give a [ __ ] where i am on
the plane it's like a five-hour
relationship make it more like a dating
app
obese nazi with a service dog swipe left
tiny asian lady with a surgical mask
that's miguel
yes she is not a talker right
but just like a dating app she shows up
with a baby i'm like i got catfished
hate the small talk two things i can't
do small talk and eye contact how sad is
that you know
i basically have all the traits of a
serial killer just without the ambition
i'm working on it people i say mark
gotta be more confident they say mark
gotta be yourself i'm like well you
gotta pick one
i can't do both of those like a lot of
people are scared of skydiving i'm more
scared of the banter on the plane than i
am jumping out of it you know
you sit in the plane it's all windy
you're strapped in some guy's like so
mark where are you from just like
it's like we're supposed to go together
i got it
at least with skydiving you get an
instructor what about stuff i'm bad at
stuff i'm nervous about like a dinner
party all my dinner parties have screwed
up set me up with a pro
right i just show up some guys like all
right i'll take care i'm like ah
beautiful he's giving me tips
don't say the n-word got it all right
she's not pregnant don't ask thank god
you're here
some guy the party's like so who's your
favorite comic i'm like bill cosby's
like pull the chute
i'm working on it i had a chatty uber
driver last week that's the worst huh
this guy wouldn't shut up
i forgot that the no small talk option
on the app so i'd get creative i had to
scare the guy into being quiet
he's like how about this traffic huh
what do you think's causing this i'm
like probably the jews he's like
like all right i give this ride five
stars of david
i uh i trav i do travel a lot if i fly
uh delta if i buy a ticket through uh
delta's system
my name in their system is nathan and on
my license my name is nathanael
i do not remember making this decision
but it's a big deal
you can't just change it i've tried i've
asked delta
and they're like we can't and you're
like all right i don't know where we go
from here
you know if you can't do it who can do
it uh do you call a senator is that what
senators do i don't know
how high do i have to go
what do you have to do you have to mail
your birth certificate in some moms give
their kids their birth certificates i've
never seen mine
i thought i was the proof of my birth
and that's
and you get you got to mail it in i'm
not i'm not a big melanin
guy uh i've mailed maybe four letters
my entire life stamps make me nervous
you know how many do you put on there i
don't know uh
and they change the price of stamps and
they don't that's not
in the news you don't find that out on
twitter you
you have to find out from old people
they're the only people that know
yeah they're telling you they're like
stamps and up you're like okay
uh and they're furious you're like is it
a hundred dollars
a stamp i've never seen you that mad
it's uh
i will never go through this process to
get my name changed so i just deal with
it
and it gets brought up i was checking
the bag once
and the guy behind the counter sees my
ticket says nathan the license says
nathanael
and he was like this is not good
he's like these names don't match and i
was like but they match right
i mean you can see the leap that we took
to get from one to the other
and he was like but they're not the same
i was like did the same and i mean at
this point i was like if this guy finds
out people call me nate
he's gonna lose his mind like he's
he's gonna call the police to be like
there's a guy with three names trying to
fight like if you guys want to shoot him
or something
so
i was like what do you want me to do and
he goes you should go home that was his
honest
i mean i can't believe you've made it
this far
i said let me try it shouldn't i just
try it you know i was like look i'll
give you
that those names don't match but what i
think is going to help a ton
is the picture on the id
i mean i think with a 100 percent face
70 percent of the name that's 170
percent
i think i'll get through he was like
look man i get it all right
he's trying to relate to me this is
honest i this is honestly what he said
he was like my name's joseph that's
what's on my license but if i buy a
ticket
under my nickname bart they're not gonna
let me through
[Applause]
those are two different names like don't
act like we're the same
growing up now must be the worst kids
just beat the [ __ ] out of you and they
emotionally [ __ ] with you on the
internet cyber bullying
feels right like when i was a kid it was
aol instant messenger not so bad
you had to make sure your parents
weren't on the phone to cyberbully you
know
you'd be like mom get off with grandma
i'm trying to ruin lives
okay [ __ ] it's a bigger it was a bigger
deal
cyberbullying now i hate when older
people are like i used to get the [ __ ]
kicked out of me log off
i'm like all right first off it's hard
to log off it's very addictive
and second off you know who wouldn't
rather be assaulted than
psychologically tormented would you
rather get a wedgie or catfished
a black guy will heal you know what
won't is uh taking a greyhound to
syracuse and being like
i thought you'd be a woman this sucks
this is the worst 13th birthday ever
[Laughter]
that joke got sadder and sadder you're
the roommate oh hell yeah this dude this
dude came straight out of woodstock i
like this guy
he's like look i had to stop at a
festival
[Laughter]
yeah i love that man what do you do for
work man i'm a designer it is not a
[ __ ] of course
[Laughter]
only a designer would have the balls to
pull this off and be like you know what
it's working i don't give a [ __ ]
yeah and i'm yeah what kind of designer
i work for cosmopolitan oh hell yeah
cosmo
given women bad advice for decades
[Music]
cosmo ladies this is what he really
wants
silence i've never seen that article
i've never seen a cosmo article give him
peace for one day
and everything will be great
are all you guys in finance no what do
you do i'm a real estate agent real
estate all right
and your mom's in real estate too his
mom
all right what do you do i work at
amazon [ __ ] part of the problem but i do
hey wait unless we sell this to amazon
in which case
very good people and
i'm gonna handle this like trump hey
they could be great people we don't know
we don't know how they feel about me
[Music]
you